as expected more rhetoric from North
Korea's short time ago the state-run
news agency KCNA issuing the statement
saying that North Korea's military is
quote examining the operational plans to
strike around a Guam with medium to long
range ballistic missiles now that's
according to the North Korean news
agency a statement from the spokesman
for the strategic force of the Korean
People's Army warns that recent u.s.
military maneuvers including a regularly
scheduled u.s. ICBM test provoke may
provoke a dangerous conflict so Guam an
American territory about 1,800 miles or
so from North Korea about 160,000 or so
people living on that Island to u.s.
military bases so there is a direct
threat to the United States here from
the North Koreans it doesn't get any
more direct than that for them to say
they are looking at a plan to attack
Guam this now puts it back in prison and
Trump's ball court of course because he
said earlier today any more threats from
the North Koreans it would be met with
that fire and fury